After two decades at the
top of a party in Congress
ushering through massive legislation,
the bill is passed.
Winning the majority twice
becoming the first woman
to lead the House
and now losing the majority
for the second time
as speaker of the House will be in order.
Nancy Pelosi announced
she would step aside.
I will not seek reelection
to Democratic leadership
in the next Congress.
For me,
the hours come for a new generation
to lead the Democratic caucus
that I so deeply respect it.
82, the Democrat has represented
San Francisco in the House for 35 years,
saying
she would continue serving in a Congress
whose makeup has markedly changed.
When I came to the Congress in 1987,
there were 12 Democratic women.
Now they're over 90 and we want more.
The news prompting an immediate shakeup.
Pelosi's current number two, Steny Hoyer
announcing that at the age of 83
he would not run for leadership
in the current number three.
82 year old Jim
Clyburn signals
he also will let a new team ascend,
paving the way for Hakeem Jeffries,
a 52 year old Brooklyn Democrat,
as the likely next Democratic leader.
I'm very comfortable saying,
I believe that every member
of the Congressional Black Caucus
would vote for Hakeem Jeffries.
Every top two deputies
could be 59 year old Katherine Clarke
and 43 year old Pete Aguilar,
someone who all expected to run
in the November 30th
leadership elections.
Hey, it's a generational change.
Some have long sought.
I think she's a historic speaker,
as accomplished an incredible amount.
But I also think
there are a lot of Democrats
ready for a new chapter.
The daughter of a Baltimore mayor
who rose the ranks in her state party
first became speaker in 2007,
leading the opposition
against George W Bush over the Iraq war.
Three years later,
shepherding through the Affordable
Care Act under Barack Obama
after her
party was swept into the minority
becoming speaker again in 2019,
where she battled Donald Trump,
making him
the only president impeached twice
including after January six.
But pro-Trump rioters stormed
the capitol in targeted the speaker.
For now, though,
can you imagine a caucus
not run by Nancy Pelosi?
Well, I hope that
we don't have to see that.